ah yes Florida man Florida man Florida
man Florida man Florida man Florida man
Florida man Florida man mister Florida
who can forget classic lore demand
stories like Florida man undergoing
kidney dialysis is upset that he can't
bring life-size cut out of President
Trump for emotional support during his
treatments Florida man threatens to kill
man with kindness uses machete named
kindness Florida man accused of stealing
Gator from Golf Course threw it around
to teach it a lesson for every US state
people have formed some stereotypes
about the people who live there for
Oregon people may unfairly assume it's
full of Portlandia hipsters for Texas
people might unfairly assume folks are
just one unkind word away from going
full Yosemite Sam now all of you
my hair
but whenever you hear the name Florida
man it conjures up a certain image of
swamps beer and Lawless shamelessness
and I'm not talking about Mar-A-Lago but
what if I told you that the overwhelming
Deluge of stories about Florida and
their Florida Antics isn't because
Floridians are inherently weird and
prone to getting caught doing ridiculous
things really the reason we hear so much
about Florida has to do with something
that should be the Envy of all other
states Florida's radical commitment to
open meetings in accessible public
records so let's discuss the phenomenon
in Florida man Florida woman and Florida
people and how we owe Florida's open
government laws for entertaining us with
stories like SWAT team rescues Florida
man from Tree Florida man blames Putin
an attempt to avoid speeding ticket and
so so many more Tales of Woe from the
Sunshine State
eight I'm a monster but before we get
into the why of Florida man let's
discuss the what of Florida man what is
Florida man well for those of you who
have spent the last decade living under
a rock with no Wi-Fi Florida man is a
long-running internet joke about
to put it politely the colorful
residents of these Sunshine States
specifically the term refers to the
singly disproportionate number of
Floridians whose news stories go viral
for engaging in a variety of irrational
sordid and outright bizarre behavior
Florida man first became popularized as
an internet meme in 2013 thanks to the
efforts of the Florida man Twitter
account who gained national attention
when he began collecting news stories
about Florida man stories to illustrate
real life headlines about the world's
worst superhero though the account
stopped tweeting in 2019 you can also
track the exploits of Florida man
stories on Reddit and Tumblr or you
could just apply Florida man to your
Google Alerts the general pattern of
these stories involve headlines that are
literally just Florida man followed by
the absolutely Bonkers thing that they
are reported to have done what kinds of
things you ask well I'm so happy you
asked because these peculiar Tales fall
into several categories of Floridian
whoa you've got your booze related
Antics like beer is my coffee says
Florida man arrested for ninth DUI
Florida man arrested on DOI charge after
driving scooter into Walmart shelves
police say drunk Florida man tries to
use Taco as ID after his car catches
fire at Taco Bell and then you've got
your drug related mishaps like Florida
man high on flakka attacked officer said
he was God had sex with tree police say
a Florida man calls cops to come over
and test if his meth is authentic
Florida man says syringes found in his
rectum aren't his then you've got
bizarre injuries often involving the
misuse of firearms explosives or
Wildlife like Florida man accidentally
shoots himself notices two days later
Florida man who blew arms off making
fireworks with coffee grinder won't be
charged Florida man fleeing from Cops
attacked by alligator then you've got
Florida crime stories like police
Florida men try to steal honey get
attacked by 30 000 bees Florida man
arrested for trying to get alligator
drunk Florida man posing as Disney
worker charged in removal of R2D2 at
hotel Florida man snatches 4 million
pounds of citrus without paying then
there are the Florida man stories that
defy categorization Florida man beats
ATM says it gave too much cash Florida
man's stole truck attempted to break
into military base to warn a fight
between aliens and Dragons Florida man
claimed powers of invincibility helped
him steal cigarettes police and unless
you think it's just all about the
Florida man we've also got our share of
Florida woman stories that are no less
bizarre like Florida woman dances during
sobriety test tells Deputy you sound
like my ballet coach Florida woman
arrested for posting fresh meth tonight
on dating profile cyber stalking Florida
Woman bites camel's genitals to escape
from animal after it sat on her the
camel did nothing wrong okay I know what
you're thinking Devin are you actually
going to talk about some kind of
pertinent legal issues here or is this
just some flimsy excuse to list as many
Florida man and Florida Women's stories
as possible in one video
yes
now I'm also going to talk about all the
crazy stuff that happens in all of the
other states as well we'll get to the
law in a second but the thing is weird
news stories exist in every state and
they're not hard to find Texas man Tex
weed offer to cop gets arrested Arizona
man selling Ranch for 5 million dollars
due to constant alien attacks
Pennsylvania man facing assault charges
over Big Mac get a good man yells at
Bear until it leaves his kitchen
Missouri man helps start Riot against
self will almost assuredly be re-elected
Senator after three more years in office
and yet there seems to be a
disproportionate amount of weird stories
coming out of Florida but there's
actually a very good reason we hear
about Florida so much in these viral
news stories and it's something that
Florida actually has done very well that
is worthy of Praise that should be
modeled by other states I'm talking
about Florida's robust public records
laws enshrined by Statute and
Constitutional Amendments as reported by
the Miami New Times ironically one of
the things that may be contributing to
Florida being shamed so often in the
National media is something all
Floridians should be proud of since 1909
Florida has had a proud tradition that
all government business is public
business and therefore should be
available to the public that means all
records including photos and videos
produced by a public agency are easily
accessible with a few narrow and obvious
exceptions public officials are also
required to open all their meetings even
on official ones to the public so here's
a quick recap of Florida's century-long
tradition of open records laws Florida
passed its first public records law in
1909 with the aptly named public records
law as stated by the Florida public
records law quote it is the policy of
the state that all state county and
Municipal records are open for personal
inspection and copying by any person
providing access to public records is a
duty of each agency under this law all
records made or received by any public
agency in the course of a visual
business are available for inspection
unless subject to a specific exception
or exclusion by the Florida legislature
and in the century that that law has
been enacted the definition of what
constitutes public record has expanded
beyond the traditional written documents
and you know what public records are
also subject to disclosure arrest
reports 9-1-1 calls and mugshots with
private info like address and phone
number is redacted as a result we got
access to Florida man stories like drunk
Florida man kicked out of Library told
cops he was Jason Bourne Florida man
with Florida tattoo on his forehead
arrested for misuse of 911 marijuana
possession Florida man suspected of
smelling woman's feet at library leads
police on scooter Chase and in 1967
Florida expanded its open records laws
even further with a passage of the
government in the Sunshine Law these
Provisions commonly called the Sunshine
Law establish a basic right of access to
most meetings of boards commissions and
other governing bodies of state and
local agencies and authorities subject
to limited exemptions the Sunshine Law
dictates that no resolution rule or
formal action taken by any governing
body or board are legally binding unless
their meetings comply with these
requirements which leads to the
publication of floor demand stories like
floored man offered to pay officer with
hamburger for oral sex police say
Florida man tells police he's allowed to
carry meth ask the FBI Florida man
claims he was driving car with two
missing tires because of a curse and
public officials who knowingly violate
these Sunshine laws are subject to a
first-degree misdemeanor charge
punishable by a fine of up to one
thousand dollars in a jail term term not
to exceed one year now an unintentional
violation is a non-criminal fine of up
to five hundred dollars and a public
official who intentionally violates the
public records law is subject to a
suspension or removal from office and
attorney's fees and court costs are
available to plaintiffs that Prevail in
a civil suit for Access and since 1967
Floridians have repeatedly voted to
enshrine open government principles into
the state constitution voters adopted
the sunshine amendment in 1976 which
required the full in public disclosure
of the financial interests of all public
officers candidates and employees and in
1990 a constitutional amendment applying
open meetings laws to the state
legislature was overwhelmingly passed by
the voters and in 1992 voters amended
the state constitution one more time to
guarantee the openness in state
government and expand public records
laws to the Judiciary and as a result
Florida couldn't hide stories like
Florida man accused of using Kool-Aid
packets to steal nearly one thousand
dollars in Walmart merchandise Florida
man arrested with pound of cocaine some
kept on stack of bacon Florida man
sprays women with roach spray breakout
nunchucks over over loud music no and
let's not just say that the laws are
solely responsible for all of the crazy
stories that come out of Florida as
highlighted by the New York Times in a
report on the subject some contributing
factors to the Florida man phenomenon
are the sheer size and diverse culture
of the state Florida is the third
largest U.S state and with more people
means more crime stories the times noted
that drugs and the weather are also
culprits Island Boy images
these steaminess adds to the seaminess
and Outdoor Living makes for easy
viewing and recording the most important
factor in Florida man's superhero origin
story is the strength of Florida's
public records laws as reported by a
local station in Tallahassee under the
sunshine act the public and the media
are given access to crime reports almost
immediately after they happen like the
daily booking report which is posted
almost as soon as a person is booked
into jail that information allows
reporters to detail the narratives
quickly Barbara Peterson the president
of Florida's first amendment Foundation
notes that the easy access coupled with
the sheer novelty makes these stories
takes off quote it's fun to say Florida
man both the fact that we do get access
to that information early on but also
The Branding and while Florida reporters
can get these arrest reports quickly
reporters in other states typically have
to file a request for an arrest record
which police can routinely deny despite
their jurisdictions purported open
records laws arrest reports like Florida
man with drugs around penis denies they
were his Florida man arrested after
hitting dad with pizza because he was
mad he helped birth him Florida man
arrested for handing out marijuana
because it was Christmas in a 2019
editorial Pennsylvania journalist Gil
smart explained the roadblocks to
getting an arrest report in the Keystone
State versus the Sunshine State as smart
explained Pennsylvania open records laws
allow police to withhold information if
it's considered part of a criminal
investigation and police would
frequently claim that we can't give you
the arrest report because it's part of
the investigation and even if police did
produce documents there was no way to
know what volume of information was
being upheld but when smart came to
Florida he was shocked by the ease with
which journalists can get information
quote law enforcement provides you with
his info as a matter of course without
complaining or throwing roadblocks in
your way or claiming it's crucial info
in an investigation just how easy was it
for smart to get these documents in
Florida well a local police agency
started sending smart daily arrest
reports by email something he didn't
even sign up for or request before
receiving them now of course the
salaciousness and silliness of these
Tales of Woe do lend themselves to a
special kind of I'm so glad it's not me
enjoyment I mean how else is one
supposed to react to Florida man
arrested for calling 9-1-1 after his
kitten was denied entry into a strip
club it's easy to chuckle at some of
these more frivolous sounding stories
but many of these headlines are deeply
disturbing and violent and critics of
the Florida man phenomenon know that the
punchline is often at the expense of
Floridians with mental health issues and
severe drug dependency mental health
issues and Drug dependency issues like
oh well maybe that's not in such great
taste and it's easy to forget that every
Florida band or Florida woman story
involves real people and it's important
not to overlook the seriousness us of
their alleged crimes even the creator of
the Florida man Twitter account has
regrets about his role in popularizing
the meme four 36 year old Freddie
champion who was raised in the United
Kingdom Florida represented a kind of
pure undiluted Americana quote I never
thought I was making fun of Florida
because Florida is America it's made up
of people who moved here five years ago
even when I think in Florida man as a
character he moved to Florida after he
faked his death in another state by 2016
36 year old Freddie champion who was
raised in the UK feared he had lost
control to me noticing that quote 90 of
the stories people were sending me were
mean-spirited in 2017 Champion briefly
stopped posting telling the Washington
Post that the comedy felt stale and that
he began questioning the ethics of what
he was doing quote how much do I want to
be a party to essentially making fun of
people on their worst day of their lives
even if they have done something wrong
like who gave the internet the right to
add to someone's punishment and now the
Twitter account is retired and Campion
hopes that other people like himself are
learning to be more responsible about
what they share online but he doesn't
seem to be quite so optimistic he said
that quote I'd still love to see Florida
man have a happy ending
and of course it's worth noting that a
lot of Florida man stories come directly
from arrest reports and other documents
containing uncontested facts produced by
the police and of course the police
might have an ax to grind or a certain
perspective to promote and then news
organizations that report what the
police say without checking any other
sources are complicit in this and they
of course get in the habit of Simply
parroting what the police tell them
which in the context of an uncontested
case of Florida man might not be the
biggest deal but it could become an
issue when things are more contested in
different contexts so remember next time
you share a crazy Florida man's story
your state citizens are just as dumb and
broken your laws are just less
transparent boom roasted of course it
was good while it lasted when the
original Sunshine Amendment passed the
only major exceptions were for bank
account numbers Social Security numbers
and medical records but Florida's
leadership is actively chipping away at
the sunshine laws Rhonda said this is
the first floor to govern to claim an
executive privilege to keep certain
government records secret the Florida
Constitution does not mention executive
privilege of any kind but a Florida
trial judge has sided with DeSantis in
applying the new privilege to Shield
emails related to how the governor
screens judges DeSantis has already
signed several bills limiting access to
information about police and police
methods and in 2023 the Florida
legislature has already introduced over
60 bills that would create exceptions to
Florida's public records acts one of the
new exceptions would prohibit the agency
would provide security for DeSantis from
disclosing any details about his travel
Arrangements even for trips that are
already covered and another would allow
courts to seal eviction proceedings upon
requests of landlords or tenants and in
2022 DeSantis signed a law creating an
exception for information about
candidates for college and university
presidencies so Florida's exceptional
Sunshine Law maybe is endangered as I
don't know some sort of animal that's
endangered in Florida the hawksbill sea
turtle or something like that of course
the information that Florida has made
public will live online forever but
unlike all of the Florida people you can
get your online personal data taken down
with today's sponsor in cogni now I
don't know about you but I've seen a
huge uptick in the amount of spam that
I'm getting and is no surprise why every
year the number and scope of data
breaches worldwide are rising and you
might not know it but there are hundreds
of data Brokers that possess and sell
your personal information and their
numbers are growing every single year
these data Brokers could have your name
your address phone numbers shopping
habits possibly even your social
security number all up for the highest
bidder and at best this leads to scam
calls and at worst to identity theft and
doxing but that's where incognate comes
in incognitive fights on your behalf to
remove your personal data from data
Brokers and deals with any objections
from their side all you have to do is
create an account and give them approval
to work on your behalf and incognitive
conducts repeated ongoing removals
because even if the broker removes your
data once they could collect it again
Incognito make sure that your personal
information stays off the market for
good when I signed up I saw a huge
decrease in the number of spam emails
and calls that I was getting and it's
terrifying to see exactly how many
Brokers have our data but it's really
fun to log into the Incognito dashboard
and watching cogni get them to delete
that info one by one so if you'd like to
give Incognito try the first 100 people
to click on the link below and use the
code legal eagle will get 60 off their
subscription to incogni so to get 60 off
just click on the link that's on screen
right now or down in the description and
use the code legal eagle to get
incognity after that click on this box
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court